eri camminai fai un video con l'hull
dovrei parlare in inglese per farlo io
oggi come posso kent laiche weekend 29
giu ok dei calmanti ai rom ai nostri
tempi
no evil geometri da journal che ne sto
per ok ho capito adesso 22 mikami
sputato per terra cazzo
[Musica]
va bene va bene basta vasta che è stato
bello macchiava blog con justin bieber
dopo quello di skrillex fantastico l a
tutti ragazzi e prevenuti avessero un
video sono fa vj oggi siamo in un nuovo
blog prima di cominciare ragazzi cosa i
tuoi di partire con la fama della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta già è stata vinta da chi di festa
non c'è scritto cosa cazzo c'è scritto
quale caparo a e ron è stata vinta da
madonna che è affatto questa parte della
madonna nel server che veramente
wow anche sul retro ce n'è un altro
strafiga però comunque non ho capito
come cosa c'è scritto sei stata molto
brava comunque grazie mille detto questo
ragazzi passiamo agli eventi la
settimana che anche questa settimana
sono epici e circa un paio di settimane
fa non mi ricordo di preciso sono andato
in sicilia per fare due raduni e nel
mentre che ogni sicilia ho fatto anche
tre giorni di vacanza questo è quello
che è successo più o meno nel mentre
[Applauso]
qui ragazzi eravamo nel backstage
dell'evento a catania è stata una roba
fuori di testa stanno risolvendo queste
cose intanto io mi faccio i cazzi miei
come se questa fosse casa mia
quanto sono simpatico credo che stia
ridendo di me ragazzi allora vivo
abbiamo scherzato insieme ci siamo
divertiti vi ho fatto anche salutare un
mio amico
bene
uno di vendere
[Applauso]
[Musica]
i ragazzi devono fare sta cosa siamo dei
figli perché sappiamo andare sappiamo
andarci cosi la prima brahms e questo fa
gira così allora significa che siamo
dove la prima decina di qua
[Musica]
riprendiamo qui dopo quando siamo in
mezzo all'oceano ciao ciao velo di mare
credo sia più un albero questo prove poi
invece la casta o provando a fare un
pezzo di blog per strada il problema è
che in sicilia non so perché mi
riconoscono 20 volte di più di fatti è
stato impossibile farlo però devo
ammettere questo pezzo perché è ridicolo
cosa succede
no è prima in te stiamo andando in the
center of the seas facciamo una foto
iniqua come si chiama la città
mondello sei un grande
l'inerzia piazzette scritto c'è scritto
incredibilmente viva la maria
meraviglioso sito quella signora ciao
caro come sai siamo figli
bene l'asia io non lo conosco premio
amico
ne approfitto per dire tanto lo sapete
già l'ho già detto miliardo di volte
semi incontrate eccetera e non abbiate
paura di chiedermi magari una foto come
se succedesse per la prima volta anche
per me è un'emozione assurdo non lo sono
anche spiegare quindi nel caso non
abbiate paura perché sono stracontento
di farvi una foto a voi e io non vi
faccio coprire la foto vi mettete in
posa vela fatto invece ragazzi eravamo
sul pedalò e diciamo che il mio amico si
è tuffato in acqua per recuperare una
palla e io stavo ancora guidando il
pedalò ragazzi non l'avesse mai fatto
l'avrei evento ha tirato sul ancora
regala mentre ho visto ancora in mare
bellissimo e dica mega poverino non
riesce a raggiungere
allora niente lui rimarrà lì ragazzi
più che chiaro
basta dai salviamoli la vita povera
cristiano via pieno dal che ho ingoiato
12 chili di saper fare stack agata prove
non è male questa la mia vasca da bagno
un po grossa il 29 novembre
ciao ragazzi ho usato in passato il
pedone l'offerta fetta ragazzi sono
tornato a casa sono tipo e le due di
notte
ho trovato questa bellissima sorpresa
sul pavimento e fantastico guardate
eccolo che bello che sei tesoro cristo
santo staccato di merda dovrei ucciderlo
in teoria visto che il grosso quanto mio
piede porca
quindi ragazzi questo è quello che è
successo durante quei tre giorni è
successo di tutto
detto questo dire che possiamo passare
al farvi risponde la prima domanda
arriva da da nùxe che sembra il nome di
un medicinale riferita al blog
precedente dove mi ero ha lanciato col
paracadute purtroppo il paracadute si è
aperto ma sei sicuro perché credo che
quella l'aprirsi fosse tua madre
la seconda domanda arrivano scusato
chiusi verità fanno i file a don't già
dicendo vari file ad onta già don't
challenge ce l'ho fatta non posso fare
la don't giorgi c'è ljajic challenge
perché sarei brutto lo stesso amo la
nutella fare sfida andrà anch'io favi ti
piacciono i penta toni siri segue un
sacco sono forse i miei coverity
preferiti in generale secondo un sacco
di cover su youtube sventato anis made
in badly voi seven i un sacco un
bordello ragazzi direi che ho finito con
il blog anche perché ho paura che torni
sciaia scia sciaia come cazzo si dice è
prima di concludere di ripassare al
affari domanda di oggi lafine amanda di
oggi è che cosa vuole che faccia ciaia
cia ciaia soia e continua sclerare nel
mio bagno
basta tavoletta del 7 senti lo sta
schierando la tavoletta nel cesso perché
non tira lo sciacquone è il bravo
braccia riusciti quindi ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto ma se rilasciato
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che condivido trattano
descrizione so se aversi distretto i
civili diavolo proseguito bella ragazza